[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis schönen guten Abend und
willkommen Fußball von Norbert Lehmann
ja mit den letzten wichtigen Infos vor
dem DFB-Pokal Topspiel Augsburg gegen
Bayern unsere Nachrichtenthemen
neue Phase im ukraine-krieg russlands
Präsident Putin verhängt das Kriegsrecht
in den vier annektierten Provinzen eine
Evakuierung in Hassan ist angelaufen
Krankenhäuser am Limit durch die
corona-herbst Welle werden viele Orts
die Intensivbetten knapp auch weil viele
Pflegekräfte ausfallen
und zu wenig Bewegung nach einer neuen
Studie der WHO sind viele Deutsche zu
träge mit verheerenden Folgen für die
Gesundheit
[Musik]
die ukrainischen Truppen rückenweiter
vor jetzt hat Kreml Chef Putin in den
annektierten Gebieten der Ostukraine das
Kriegsrecht verhängt das verkündete er
bei einer Rede im Nationalen
Sicherheitsrat es soll um Mitternacht in
Kraft treten
mit dem Kriegsrecht können die
russischen Besatzer die Bürgerrechte in
denen völkerrechtswidrig annektierten
Gebieten noch stärker einschränken
gleichzeitig geraten die russischen
Truppen offenbar weiter unter Druck vor
allem in Fasson die prorussischen
Behörden und die Zivilbevölkerung sollen
aufs andere Ufer des denipro gebracht
werden in Erwartung einer ukrainischen
Offensive Christina gröntgen berichtet
die aktuelle Situation mache es
notwendig sagt Putin und verkündet am
Nachmittag im Staatsfernsehen ich habe
einen Dekret zur Einführung des
Kriegsrechts unterzeichnet
den Gouverneuren in denen gerade erst
völkerrechtswidrig annektierten Regionen
räumt Putin mehr Befugnisse ein
besonders im Fokus presshon im Süden des
Landes das ukrainische Truppen
zurückerobern wollen ein Großangriff
steht aus russischer Sicht kurz bevor
für die Bevölkerung heißt das sie müssen
sich jetzt auf Kriegshandlungen gefasst
machen sie müssen sich auf erhebliche
Eingriffe auch gefasst machen in ihrem
Privatleben aber auch in den Betrieben
oder auch bei den bei der sicheren der
Verkehrswege es kann so Ausgangssperren
kommen es kann zur evakuieren kommen
alles das wird jetzt stattfinden schon
jetzt zeigen russische Medien tausende
Menschen die auf fairen warten die sie
auf die andere Seite des Flusses näher
bringen bis zu 60.000 Zivilisten so
heißt es sollen die Stadt verlassen auch
die gesamte russische Verwaltung wird
aus reson abgezogen
es ist notwendig diese Gebiete zu
verlassen damit die Militärs in Ruhe
arbeiten und nicht daran denken dass
Zivilisten hinter ihrem Rücken stehen
damit die Militärs ihre Arbeit effizient
und mit weniger Verlusten für die
Zivilbevölkerung erledigen können
[Musik]
für alle in Hessen aber auch in den
anderen besetzten Gebieten bedeutet das
nun verhängte Kriegsrecht noch mehr
Einschränkungen noch mehr Eingriffe in
ihr Leben im Krieg
gehen wir zu unserem korspondenten in
der Ukraine und unserer Korrespondentin
in Russland und zuerst zu ihnen Vögel
nach Moskau was hat die Verhängung des
kriegsrechtsverfolgen
also zunächst einmal hat Vladimir Putin
damit den rechtlichen Rahmen geschaffen
für etwas das in den besetzten Gebieten
eigentlich schon seit Monaten Realität
ist interessant ist aber was noch in dem
Dekret steht etwas weiter hinten nämlich
da ordnet der Präsident eine erhöhte
Alarmbereitschaft an für große Teile
Russlands und das bedeutet dass jetzt
auch in Moskau oder in anderen
Metropolen und Regionen Ausgangssperren
oder eben zum Beispiel
Reisebeschränkungen angeordnet werden
können und das wiederum heißt dass
sozusagen im Schatten dieses jetzt viel
diskutierten Kriegsrechts für die
besetzten Regionen auch Vorkehrungen
getroffen werden die dann im im Effekt
quasi großen Einfluss hätten auf das
Leben der Russinnen und Russen und die
diese militärische spezialoperation wie
es hier ja immer noch heißt wieder ein
Stück näher in ihre Leben bringen würde
und daran wie reagiert auf diese
Verhängung des Kriegsrechts
ja der ukrainische präsidentenberater
podalliak sprach direkt von
scheinlegalisierung pseudo-legalisierung
für blutplünder rein und er sagte die
Ukraine werde die Befreiung der
besetzten Gebiete direkt fortführen doch
das Kriegsrecht das wird gelten in den
Gebieten und dort wählen wohnen
Millionen von Menschen die genaue Zahl
ist nicht bekannt und viele von ihnen
sind pro Ukrainisch da gibt es einen
Passus der sagt dass man zur
territorialen Verteidigung eingezogen
werden kann und das würde bedeuten denn
so könnte es passieren das
pro-okrainische Menschen an der Seite
der Russen gegen die ukrainische Armee
kämpfen müssten und das wird in diesem
Moment wahrscheinlich sehr viele
Menschen dort erschaudern lassen danke
für diese Einschätzung da hast unser Tee
und für Becker
Russland wird in seinem Angriffskrieg
unterstützt von Iran und zwar mit
Drohnen dafür gebe es nun genügend
Beweise so die EU-Kommission deshalb
bringt die EU nun Sanktionen gegen Iran
auf den Weg russland hatte die Ukraine
den vergangenen Tagen mehrfach mit
iranischen kampfdrohen vom Typ Shahid
136 angegriffen die Strafmaßnahmen
sollen die treffen die für den Bau und
die Lieferung der Drohnen an Russland
verantwortlich sind teheran bestreitet
Russland mit Drohnen beliefert zu haben
mit dem Einsatz der sogenannten
kamikazedonen beschäftigt sich auch
heute live ab 19.30 bei ZDF heute und
auf unseren Social Media Kanälen
mit dem renommierten Sacharow-Preis für
Menschenrechte ehrt das EU-Parlament in
diesem Jahr die ukrainische Bevölkerung
zur Begründung sagte
Parlamentspräsidentin Mezzola wörtlich
die Menschen in Ukraine setzen ihr Leben
auch für Europa auf Spiel um die Werte
zu schützen an die wir alle glauben
Freiheit Demokratie Rechtsstaatlichkeit
zwei Tage nach dem Machtwort von Kanzler
Scholz im Atomstreit war heute das
Kabinett am Zug ist billigte ein
Gesetzentwurf zum Weiterbetrieb der
verbliebenen drei Atomkraftwerke bis
Mitte April so stimmen muss noch der
Bundestag und Bundesrat das könnte im
November geschehen
beschlossen hat das Bundeskabinett heute
auch ein ehrgeizigen Plan zur
Elektromobilität eine Million
öffentliche Ladestation sollen
geschaffen werden bis 2030 das Argument
von Bundesverkehrsminister Wissing
fahren mit Strom werde nur dann populär
wenn es überall Strom für die Autos gibt
dafür ist aber noch viel zu tun denn
bislang gibt es nur 70.000 Ladepunkte
mattis Feldhoff
schon vor ein paar Wochen auf einem
ladesäulengipfel seines Ministeriums
präsentiert sich Volker Wissing mit
Stromkabel und E-Auto die Botschaft
damals wie heute der Ausbau der
e-lademöglichkeiten ist jetzt Chefsache
des Ministers die Elektromobilität wird
nur Akzeptanz finden wenn das Laden so
einfach ist wie heute das Tanken und es
darf nicht zu dem berühmten
henna-ei-problemen kommen
jede
Negativerfahrung mit Elektromobilität
erschwert den Umstieg auf
klimafreundliche Antriebe 6,3 Milliarden
Euro will der Bund in die Lade
Infrastruktur investieren die Zahl der
öffentlichen Ladesäulen soll von heute
70.000 auf eine Million bis zum Jahr
2030 gesteigert werden es ist schön dass
er wissen jetzt versucht Tempo und diese
Sache zu bringen aber er hat vergessen
die wichtigste Maßnahme zu ergreifen und
das ist ein Ausstiegsdatum für den
Verbrenner das deutsche Ladenetz soll
beispielgebend in Europa werden eng
verzahnt mit dem flächendeckenden
Stromnetz und privaten Ladesäulen am
besten Solarstrom betrieben Lücken in
ländlichen Gebieten soll es nicht geben
das Hemmnis der hohen Strompreise würde
nicht ewig bestehen so Wissing heute
Verkehrsverbände sind nicht so
optimistisch natürlich erhöht das die
Unsicherheiten noch mal mehr und umso
wichtiger wird es sein dass tatsächlich
alle mitziehen und dass die
Nutzerfreundlichkeit ganz groß
geschrieben wird also das ist zumindest
bei deinem Alltagstauglichkeit der
Fahrzeuge und der Elektromobilität keine
Fragezeichen gibt
weitgehend gelöst ist der europäischen
Markt das Problem der unterschiedlichen
Ladestecker Typ 2 Stecker für normales
laden und ccs-stecker für Schnellladen
sind inzwischen Standard
Krankenhaus
pflegeentlastungsgesetz hinter diesem
Wort Ungetüm verbirgt sich ein Plan von
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach er will
Kliniken verpflichten genügend
Pflegekräfte zu haben dazu soll ein
neuer Personalschlüssel her heute hat
der Bundestag den Gesetzentwurf beraten
in vielen Krankenhäusern ist die Lage
zur Zeit ja ohnehin schwierig wegen
Corona die hospitalisierungsrate die ihr
angibt wie viele Menschen mit cowitt 19
pro 100.000 EinwohnerInnen in einer
Woche in Kliniken eingewiesen werden
liegt heute bundesweit bei 12,61 das ist
sehr hoch gleichzeitig gibt es beim
Personal viele Krankmeldungen und zudem
leiden die Kliniken noch unter den hohen
Energiekosten was all das bedeutet
zeigen Eva Schiller und Sven Klaas
jeder kliniktag ist im Moment eine
zitterparty Monika Schempp checkt die
neuen Belegungszahlen wieder mehr
Patienten wieder viele Kranke Kollegen
manchmal bin ich schon vor meine
Mitarbeiter da um zu sehen kann ich die
Schichten überhaupt besetzen wenn Sie
eine Planung mit fünf Mitarbeitern auf
einer Abteilung haben und es melden sich
zwei krank dann bedeutet das für die
anderen fast schon die doppelte Leistung
Personalausfälle wo es an Personal eh
schon mangelt die Kliniken müssen Betten
sperren teilweise Stationen schließen
gleichzeitig hat sich die Zahl der
covid-patienten hier in den letzten
Tagen verdreifacht über 60% der
Patienten kommen nicht wegen sondern mit
Corona aber für das ausgelaugte
Klinikpersonal ist die Belastung immens
bisher haben wir sehr intensiv mit dem
Mangel an Personal Arbeiten gelernt
jetzt ist es allerdings so dass wir an
einem Scheideweg stehen bisher konnten
wir unsere Organisation gut aufrecht
erhalten quasi alle Operationen wie
geplant durchführen jetzt aber werden
wir Entscheidungen treffen müssen
Eingriffe die Plan was sind zu
verschieben und zusätzlich kämpfen auch
sie mit explodierenden Energie und
Materialkosten einer Umfrage zufolge
sehen fast 40 Prozent der Krankenhäuser
ihre finanzielle Situation kritisch fast
alle fühlen sich von der Politik im
Stich gelassen das heißt dass man davon
ausgehen muss dass einzelne
krankenhausstandorte tatsächlich ihre
Leistung massiv einschränken müssen bzw
sogar ganz schließen müssen und das ist
eine Situation die die Politik sehenden
Auges im Moment noch in Kauf nimmt und
so wächst beim Klinikpersonal die Wut
über fehlenden Rückhalt nach fast drei
Jahren Pandemie denn während viele
Menschen das Wort Corona nicht mehr
hören wollen müssen sie sich der dritten
herbstwelle entgegenstellen
in Großbritannien beträgt die Inflation
aktuell
10,1%. so hoch war die Preissteigerung
seit 40 Jahren nicht gleichzeitig wird
es für die neue britische
Premierministerin Trust immer enger
ihren Plan die Wirtschaft durch massive
Steuererleichterungen anzuschieben
musste sie zurücknehmen die Opposition
fordert ihren Rücktritt und auch ihre
tori-partei ist alles andere als
zufrieden mit Trust heute stellte sie
sich im Parlament den Fragen der
Abgeordneten Yasin herlein
jeder neue Tag ist inzwischen ein Kampf
ums Überleben für List Trust die
Herausforderung heute für die
Premierministerin die aktuelle
Fragestunde im Parlament der sie sich
anders als am Montag noch diesmal auch
stellte ich habe im nationalen Interesse
gehandelt um wirtschaftliche Stabilität
sicherzustellen viele würden genau das
jedoch bezweifeln Rückblick Trust war
keine drei Wochen im Amt als sie ihren
Finanzminister quasi quartang ihr
wichtigstes politikversprechen einlösen
ließ massive Steuersenkungen vor allem
für Reiche um die Wirtschaft anzukurbeln
das sei allerdings nicht durchgerechnet
befanden die Finanzmärkte das Pfund
stürzte ab die Bank of England musste
mit dem Aufkauf von Anleihen stützend
eingreifen wenn ich später feuerte Trust
ihren Finanzminister der neue vollführte
dann zum vorläufigen Höhepunkt der
britischen Politik Chaos Tage am Montag
die Mutter aller kehrtwänden und nahm
alle Maßnahmen zurück den Briten bleibt
nur sich zu wundern dabei ist Trust
nicht einmal vom Volk gewählt sondern
nach Boris Johnson Sturz lediglich von
den Mitgliedern der konservativen Partei
bestimmt worden dass alles ist ein
gefundenes Fressen für die Opposition
steuersatzkürzung weg
körperschaftsteuerkürzung weg zwei Jahre
energiepreisbremse weg steuerfreies
Einkaufen Weg wirtschaftspolitische
Glaubwürdigkeit Weg alles weg warum nur
ist sie noch hier
Antwort listras ich bin eine Kämpferin
und kein Drückeberger
ob das reicht Wagen die meisten
Beobachter zu bezweifeln am späten
Nachmittag musste Trust jetzt auch noch
ihre Innenministerin auswechseln
stabiles regieren sieht anders aus
zum Schluss schauen wir noch auf eine
neue Studie der
Weltgesundheitsorganisation WHO sereetzo
150 Minuten Bewegung in der Woche um
Krankheiten wie Diabetes oder Demenz
vorzubeugen und sie zeigt gut ein
Viertel der Weltbevölkerung schafft das
nicht und deutschland schneidet
besonders schlechter
44% der Frauen und 40 Prozent der Männer
müssten sich lauter who mehr bewegen
dramatisch sind die Zahlen bei den
Jugendlichen 88 Prozent der Mädchen und
80% der jungen bewegen sich zu wenig
Lothar Becker berichtet
Schulsport für viele Jugendliche in
Deutschland die einzige Zeit echter
Bewegung
Julia Thompson ist Lehrerin und
diplom-sportwissenschaftlerin sie
beobachtet teils eklatante
fitness-probleme bei Jugendlichen und
Kindern
es gibt Kinder die sind übergewichtig
und haben dementsprechend auch
Haltungsschäden haben dann auch schon
Rückenprobleme die Muskulatur ist
eigentlich gar nicht ausgeprägt der
ganze Bewegungsapparat stimmt in sofern
nicht dass sie gewisse haltungsübungen
gar nicht machen können wer schon in
jungen Jahren körperlich nicht fit ist
erkrankt laut Studie der WHO öfter und
schwerwiegender Gesundheitsexperte Ingo
frohböse empfiehlt für den Anfang kleine
Sportübungen die können leicht in den
Alltag integriert werden er die beste
Trainingsstätte letztendlich ist Alltags
ist das Treppenhaus das muss man ganz
klar sagen nimmt man eine Stufe immer
von eins zu eins trainiert mein
Herz-Kreislauf-System nimmt man zwei
Stufen auf einmal trainiert bei dem
Muskulatur
Erwachsene gehen mit gutem oder
schlechtem Beispiel voran Eltern
besonders für Kinder heißt das Sport
oder kein Sport ist auch eine Frage der
Prioritäten zu Hause mit der Schule habe
ich da nicht so viel Zeit weil wir
schreiben ja auch arbeiten und so und
dann muss ich auch lernen ich mag es
einfach Fußball zu spielen mir macht das
einfach krass ich könnte einfach
durchgehend spielen ich gehe auch in ein
Verein in ein Basketballverein und es
macht also es macht sehr viel Spaß
einfach nur Sport zu machen ich mache
Kickboxen und ab und zu mal spiele ich
auch mit meinen Freunden draußen Fußball
zweieinhalb Stunden Bewegung pro Woche
sollten es sein auch für Erwachsene aber
Entwarnung Bewegung das können auch
ausgedehnte Herbstspaziergänge sein
und natürlich wir haben schon gehört
Fußball fußball ist immer gut zur
Bewegung Norbert du fängst ja mit
Fußball an Schalke 04 sucht einen neuen
Trainer wieder mal muss man sagen erst
der Absturz der Königsblauen in der Liga
auf einen Abstiegsplatz dann gestern
Abend im Pokal die eins zu fünf Klatsche
in Hoffenheim da war klar der glücklose
Frank Kramer muss gehen
die Mannschaft steht nach dem Spiel am
Stadion Pranger nach einem für Schalkes
Vereinsführung unwürdigen auftritt ist
der Trainer nicht mehr zu halten der
schalkerpokal arbeitet in Hoffenheim
gleicht einem Untergang 5 Gegentore in
gut einer Stunde am Tag darauf wird
Cheftrainer Frank karmer mit sofortiger
Wirkung von seinen Aufgaben entbunden
das Training leiten Assistenztrainer ein
Nachfolger wird nicht bekannt gegeben
nur vier Monate war Kramer im Amt er war
der sechste Trainer auf Schalke in den
letzten zwei Jahren
ja und die Überraschung gestern Abend
Darmstadt Sieg gegen Gladbach der
Zweitliga-Spitzenreiter ging durch
Philipp Tietz in der 23 minute in
Führung die Borussia könnte erst zu
Beginn der zweiten Halbzeit durch lokale
Netz ausgleichen ja und dann in der 79
Minute das entscheidende 2:1 durch Aaron
Seidel ein verdienter Sieg der Lilien
gegen den Bundesligisten
und alle Spiele alle Tore der gestrigen
und auch der heutigen pokalpartien bei
uns zu sehen bei ZDF heute die und in
der ZDF heute App ja und gleich live zu
sehen bei uns im ZDF Augsburg gegen
Bayern Jochen Breyer das dürfte spannend
werden
oh ja das dürfte sogar sehr spannend
werden denn die Augsburger sind
natürlich klar Außenseiter aber sie
wissen wie man die Bayern besiegt bei
den letzten beiden Duellen hier in
diesem Stadion zu Hause gegen die Bayern
hat Augsburg gewonnen hier der letzte
Sieg vor gerade mal viereinhalb Wochen
das wollen die Bayern natürlich nicht
noch mal erleben und der FC Bayern ist
in den letzten beiden pokaljahren
jeweils in der zweiten Runde
ausgeschieden noch mal heute in der
zweiten Runde rauszugehen das wäre dann
schon eine ordentliche Schmach für den
Rekordpokalsieger also es könnte ein
sehr heißer Pokalabend werden wir melden
uns um 20:15 Uhr hier aus Augsburg ja
danke Jochen
so jetzt macht du fertig Jana ich muss
nach Hause Fußball gucken
wir brauchen noch Zeit für die
Lottozahlen diese Zahlen wurden gezogen
die Gewinnzahlen lauten 1 15 23 36 40 49
Superzahl ist die 2 weitere Gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto.zdf.de und im ZDF
Text auf Seite 557
das Wetter wird wechselhafter aber es
bleibt weiter mild die Details hat
gleich Christa Orben für Sie das heute
journal können Sie in der Halbzeitpause
des DFB-Pokals sehen gegen 21 Uhr mit
Marietta Slomka tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend ab morgen bringt uns dieses
Tief hier von Westen her wechselhafteres
Wetter und es pumpt immer weiter diese
ungewöhnlichen milde Luft zu uns und
heute Nacht haben wir es auch wieder mit
dichtem Nebel zu tun vor allem im Süden
und in Mitteldeutschland von Westen
werden die Wolken dichter im Osten ist
es meist klar und das spüren wir
deutlich an den frühtemperaturen die
sinken hier auf drei bis null Grad das
bedeutet häufig Bodenfrost und reif
kratzen unter den Wolken da bleibt es
bei 11 Grad morgen steigen die
Temperaturen aber rasch wieder an im
Nordosten immerhin auf 12 bis 16 Grad im
Südwesten wieder auf 14 bis 22 Grad am
Oberrhein dazu breiten sich von Westen
her die Schauer im Tagesverlauf aus bis
zu einer Linie bis zur niedersächsischen
Nordseeküste und dem Schwarzwald und
Nachmittag sind auch kurze Gewitter mit
dabei anders im Osten von der Ostsee bis
nach Ostbayern gibt es viel Sonne für
alle frisch der Südostwind aus am
Freitag kommt aus Südwesten ein neuer
Schwall Regen und dann auch kräftigere
Gewitter am Samstag gibt es davon noch
die Reste am Sonntag viele Wolken aber
nur noch ab und zu ist das mal nass und
es bleibt am Wochenende weiter so
unglaublich mild mit 14 bis 23 Grad
tschüss